Dimanche dernier, nous avons défini à l'aide des versets 1 à 4 ce qu'est l'acception de personne.
Et nous l'avons défini comme étant un péché.
Un péché qui consiste à, je rappelle la définition de la semaine dernière,
traiter quelqu'un selon des critères humains, charnels, qui sont superficiels, partiaux ou intéressés par l'apparence, la richesse, le statut,
plutôt que selon la justice, la vérité et l'amour de l'Évangile.
Et nous nous sommes davantage concentrés sur la première partie de cette définition,
en explorant l'origine ténébreuse de ce péché,
les pensées mauvaises que nous avons même décrites comme sataniques qu'il y a derrière ce péché.
En effet, cette attitude trouve son origine dans notre chair,
dans laquelle il demeure, malheureusement, même après notre nouvelle naissance,
un reste de l'esprit de Satan, un reste de l'esprit de ce monde,
qui continue de vouloir nous attirer loin de Dieu et de sa volonté.
Satan était l'une des créatures, si ce n'est la créature la plus merveilleuse de Dieu.
Il est décrit dans la Bible comme un modèle de perfection, parfait en beauté.
Mais tout changea le jour où son cœur s'est enorgueilli de sa beauté
et où il a corrompu sa sagesse par son éclat.
Satan a regardé à ce qui frappait ses yeux, l'éclat de sa propre beauté.
Et dans son cœur désormais rempli d'orgueil est né le sombre désir d'élever son trône au-dessus des étoiles de Dieu,
de devenir semblable au très haut.
Mais aucune créature ne peut devenir semblable au très haut.
Alors Satan, consumé par son orgueil démesuré et inassouvi, a réfléchi à un moyen.
Et s'il ne pouvait pas s'élever jusqu'au trône de Dieu pour y prendre sa place,
alors il abaisserait au plus bas toutes les autres créatures de Dieu
et détournerait leur adoration de leur créateur vers lui.
Par soif de s'élever à la hauteur de Dieu, mais ne le pouvant pas,
Satan abaissa les plus faibles que lui.
Et il continue de faire cela jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Vous pouvez lire dans les premiers chapitres de la Bible en Genèse
comment Satan s'y est pris pour enrôler à sa suite l'humanité dans sa rébellion contre Dieu.
Et malheureusement pour nous et l'ensemble de la création, il a réussi.
En faisant croire à Ève, au même mensonge qui avait corrompu son cœur,
qu'elle pouvait être semblable à Dieu,
il réussit à les faire désobéir, elle et son mari,
à la seule interdiction de Dieu,
en mangeant le fruit de l'arbre de la connaissance du bien et du mal.
Ce jour-là, Satan a réussi à insuffler son esprit,
c'est-à-dire ses valeurs, ses motivations, ses méthodes, ses objectifs,
dans la chair d'Adam et Ève,
dont toute leur descendance, mis à part Jésus-Christ, a hérité par la suite.
Depuis ce jour, chaque être humain est conçu dans le péché.
Dès notre naissance, nous voulons accomplir les désirs de notre Père le diable,
comme l'enseigna notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et ce désir consiste à vouloir, comme Satan,
s'élever à la hauteur de Dieu,
en abaissant les plus faibles que nous.
Désormais, comme Satan,
l'homme s'évalue lui-même et les autres
en regardant à ce qui frappe les yeux.
Le cœur de l'homme est devenu plus attaché à l'apparence de richesse,
à l'apparence de gloire, à l'apparence de réussite
et de sainteté même dans la religion
qu'à la véritable justice d'un cœur droit aux yeux de Dieu.
John MacArthur a dit dans un sermon que j'écoutais cette semaine,
« L'orgueil est en effet la racine de tous les péchés,
car tout péché est l'expression de notre refus d'accorder à Dieu
la place qui est la sienne. »
Voici donc ce qui est à l'origine de tous nos péchés,
et particulièrement du péché d'acception de personnes
ou favoritisme, décrit par Jacques au verset 1 à 4.
Et vous verrez que beaucoup d'attitudes humaines,
beaucoup de phénomènes de société
deviendront bien plus clairs pour vous
en les abordant avec cette perspective.
L'homme corrompu par le péché veut dès sa naissance,
comme Satan, s'élever au plus haut,
au détriment des autres.
Mais même s'il y parvient,
aussi élevé, digne et glorieux soit-il aux yeux des hommes,
aux yeux de Dieu,
il n'en reste pas moins un cadavre spirituel putréfié
qui tente de maquiller sa laideur
par une apparence de richesse et de gloire.
Satan n'a pas perdu son apparence de beauté parfaite
après sa rébellion,
mais sa beauté intérieure, oui.
Il est devenu un sépulcre blanchi
qui paraît beau au dehors
et qui au-dedans est plein d'ossements,
de morts et de toutes espèces d'impuretés.
À qui le Christ adressa ces mots ?
Aux pharisiens.
À qui il dit aussi qu'ils étaient ces enfants du diable
qui veulent accomplir la volonté de leur père,
qui aiment les meilleures places dans les synagogues
et la gloire qui vient des hommes
plutôt que celle qui vient de Dieu
et qui dévorent la maison des veuves.
Commencez-vous à voir le schéma qui se répète.
C'est tout simplement encore et toujours
l'esprit du diable qui est à l'œuvre dans la chair de l'homme pécheur
dès sa naissance, le poussant à se glorifier
dans son apparence en méprisant la réalité intérieure de son âme.
guidé par cet esprit satanique, cet esprit du monde,
la chair va donc vouloir honorer tout ce qui a l'apparence de gloire
et aussi rejeter tout ce qui lui rappelle sa vraie condition spirituelle devant Dieu.
Et c'est exactement ce que font les membres d'église
auxquels Jacques écrit lorsqu'ils disent aux riches
qui portent l'anneau d'or et l'habit magnifique
« Toi, assieds-toi ici à cette place d'honneur »
et lorsqu'ils disent aux pauvres, misérablement vêtus
« Toi, tiens-toi là debout »
ou bien assieds-toi au-dessous de mon marchepied.
Ces chrétiens font alors, comme le dit Jacques au verset 4,
une distinction, un jugement sous l'inspiration de pensées mauvaises.
Très mauvaises en effet.
Puisqu'il s'agit ni plus ni moins que des pensées du diable
comme nous l'avons bien développé la semaine dernière.
Et c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que l'acception de personne est un péché si grave,
une attitude si évidemment incompatible avec le Dieu que nous adorons
et incohérente avec le message de son évangile.
Et c'est justement sur ces aspects d'incompatibilité et d'incohérence
que nous allons nous concentrer
dans les deux prochaines prédications,
en commençant aujourd'hui par l'incompatibilité.
La semaine dernière, nous avons décrit l'origine satanique de ce péché
et le schéma de pensée corrompu qu'il y a derrière ce péché.
Et c'était un examen nécessaire,
mais assez sombre et triste,
des effets du péché encore présents dans notre chair.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons voir de manière plus positive
comment ce péché est totalement incompatible
avec le caractère de notre grand Dieu,
avec la nature et l'appel de son peuple que nous sommes.
En temps normal, nous étudions,
lorsque nous étudions la théologie,
nous commençons par étudier l'être de Dieu,
les œuvres de Dieu,
avant d'en tirer des implications sur les autres sujets d'étude.
Mais comme je suis un mauvais élève,
nous n'avons pas suivi cet ordre,
mais nous allons remédier à cela ce matin.
Ceux qui étaient là dimanche dernier,
peut-être que vous vous souvenez
sur quoi nous avions conclu la prédication.
Nous avions commencé à évoquer
le remède au péché du favoritisme.
remède qui consiste à constamment tourner nos regards
ensemble vers notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
afin que l'éclat de sa gloire
consomme tout désir de gloire personnelle
que nous pourrions encore avoir
et que son magnifique manteau de justice
dont chacun de nous est revêtu
soit le seul dont nous nous glorifions désormais.
Eh bien, ce matin, nous allons commencer
à mettre en pratique ce remède.
Nous allons tourner nos regards
vers notre grand Dieu,
vers ses attributs,
son caractère, ses œuvres,
et constater, frères et sœurs,
à quelle fréquence
et avec quelle clarté
il se présente dans sa parole
comme étant le Dieu des plus pauvres
et des plus démunis de ce monde.
Et nous verrons ensuite les implications
que cette glorieuse réalité
sur notre Dieu a pour nous,
en tant que peuple de Dieu.
Verset 5
Écoutez, mes frères bien-aimés,
Dieu n'a-t-il pas choisi
les pauvres aux yeux du monde ?
Si nous n'étions pas encore convaincus
que l'acception de personne
était une mauvaise attitude,
un péché devant Dieu
grâce aux versets 2 et 3,
nourri par des pensées iniques
décrites aux versets 4,
Jacques en fait maintenant appel
à Dieu lui-même
afin d'achever de nous convaincre.
Et on sent qu'il change légèrement de ton
dans ce verset.
Il s'adresse à nouveau
à ses destinataires en disant
« Écoutez, mes frères »
mais en ajoutant « Bien-aimés ».
Un peu
comme s'il leur disait affectueusement
« Enfin, mes enfants,
ouvrez les yeux,
reprenez-vous.
Votre attitude n'a aucun sens.
Dieu ne vous a-t-il pas choisi,
vous, les pauvres,
aux yeux du monde
pour que vous soyez riches
en la foi et héritiers de son royaume ?
N'êtes-vous donc pas vous-mêmes
comptés parmi les pauvres
aux yeux du monde ? »
Dieu aime, protège
et soigne les pauvres.
Et cela n'est pas propre
au ministère Thérèse de Christ
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Vous serez étonné comme je l'ai été
si vous vous lancez
dans l'étude de ce sujet
d'une onde de versets
où Dieu se présente
comme le pourvoyeur,
le protecteur,
le vengeur
de la veuve,
de l'orphelin
et de l'étranger,
les catégories de personnes
les plus pauvres et vulnérables
dans le contexte des écrits
de l'Ancien Testament
comme du Nouveau Testament.
Et on pourrait d'ailleurs
se poser la question
« Pourquoi ? »
Pourquoi Dieu se présente-t-il
comme étant,
comme il est dit
en Ésaïe 25, verset 4,
« un refuge pour le faible,
un refuge pour le malheureux
dans la détresse,
celui qui ne fait point
exception des personnes
et qui ne reçoit point
de présent,
c'est-à-dire qui ne se laisse
pas corrompre,
qui fait droit à l'orphelin
et à la veuve
qui aime l'étranger
et lui donne de la nourriture
et des vêtements ? »
Pourquoi ce soin particulier
est-il de Dieu envers les pauvres ?
Puisque après tout,
comme nous l'avons évoqué
dimanche dernier,
la richesse était la norme
avant la chute
et elle le sera dans l'éternité.
Et la pauvreté
est une conséquence
de la chute.
Alors pourquoi Dieu ne serait-il
pas plutôt
le Dieu des riches ?
Encore une fois,
c'est le péché
qui est venu tout bouleverser.
Dieu ne change pas.
Il est toujours
le Dieu des riches.
En vérité,
il est le Dieu
de toutes les catégories
de personnes.
Mais avant la chute,
la richesse n'était
ni une source d'orgueil,
ni d'incrédulité,
ni de gloire personnelle,
ni d'oppression
du plus pauvre,
ni d'aveuglement
sur notre condition spirituelle.
Mais après la chute,
il est très clair
à la lumière de la parole
et de l'histoire
que la richesse
attise le péché.
Et nous avons vu
dimanche dernier
pourquoi l'apparence
de richesse
est l'un des meilleurs
outils de Satan
pour nourrir notre chair
corrompue par son esprit.
Nous devons reconnaître
que dans leur très grande majorité,
les riches
ont plus de mal
à admettre
qu'ils ont besoin d'aide,
que tout leur argent
est impuissant
pour améliorer
leurs conditions spirituelles
devant Dieu.
Et cela est directement lié
à leur prospérité matérielle.
Ils sont tellement habitués
à pouvoir régler
tous leurs problèmes
par l'argent
que l'idée
de demander de l'aide
ne leur vient même pas
à l'esprit
et serait même vue
comme une honte.
Même aux yeux
des autres plus pauvres,
le riche peut être vu
comme n'ayant pas besoin d'aide,
car déjà béni
et donc approuvé
par Dieu.
Cette idée
était tellement ancrée
dans les mentalités
au temps de Jésus
qu'après avoir enseigné
qu'il est difficile
à un riche d'entrer
dans le royaume des cieux,
ses disciples
furent très étonnés
et dire
« Mais qui donc
peut être sauvé ?
Si ce riche
ne peut entrer
dans le royaume,
comment nous,
pauvres,
allons pouvoir entrer ? »
Pourtant,
les bénédictions apparentes
peuvent en réalité
être un jugement
de la part de Dieu.
L'homme qui regarde
à ce qui frappe les yeux
aura l'impression
qu'il est béni de Dieu.
Mais Dieu qui regarde
au cœur
saura qu'il est en réalité
en train d'endurcir
le cœur de cet homme
dans son péché,
par son péché.
Très souvent,
Dieu endurcit
le cœur d'un homme
en lui donnant abondamment
ce que son cœur
mauvais désire.
Un tel homme
aura l'impression
que tout va bien,
cette fameuse illusion
entretenue par Satan
à l'aide de la prospérité
matérielle,
alors qu'en réalité,
loin de s'approcher
du paradis,
il s'enfonce
toujours plus profondément
en enfer
le sourire aux lèvres.
À l'inverse du riche,
après la chute,
le pauvre illustre
la condition spirituelle
misérable
de chaque homme.
La totale dépendance
et le besoin
complet du secours
de Dieu
que chaque homme a.
Mais les pauvres
ne font pas que illustrer
la réalité spirituelle
de notre chair.
Expérimenter le manque
jusqu'à la pauvreté,
peut-être,
peut véritablement
nous rendre plus sensibles
au message de l'Évangile.
D'ailleurs,
si nos conditions de vie
n'avaient aucun lien,
aucun impact
sur notre santé spirituelle,
alors pourquoi Dieu
nous ferait traverser
telle ou telle situation
de vie
pour nous sanctifier ?
Nous devons
simplement reconnaître
qu'il y a des situations
de vie
qui favorisent
l'orgueil de la chair,
l'aveuglement
et la surdité spirituelle
et des situations
de vie
qui favorisent
l'humilité
et la prise de conscience
du besoin
d'être secouru.
C'est un fait indéniable.
Jésus-Christ
n'a-t-il pas enseigné
qu'il est plus dur
à un riche d'entrer
dans le royaume des cieux
qu'à un chameau
d'entrer
dans le trou d'une aiguille ?
Dieu se désigne donc
comme le Dieu des pauvres
dans le cadre
de la création
post-chute,
corrompue
par le péché.
Et ce qu'il faut
comprendre en réalité
derrière cette formulation
qui c'est vrai,
peu prêté
à confusion,
c'est l'expression
du caractère
d'un Dieu
qui ne change pas.
Dieu
est la vérité,
il aime la vérité
et donc
il est juste
il combat
l'injustice
et ceux
qui la pratiquent.
Et qui subit
le plus l'injustice
dans ce monde déchu ?
Les plus pauvres.
Dieu
est généreux,
il pourvoit,
il protège
et qui est le plus démuni
et en danger
dans ce monde déchu ?
Les plus pauvres.
Dieu
ne rejette
jamais celui
qui vient à lui.
Il entend
les cris
de ceux
qui l'appellent
à l'aide.
Et qui est
le plus délaissé
dans ce monde déchu ?
Qui a le plus
besoin d'aide ?
Les plus pauvres.
Vous pouvez
être certains
que Dieu
fera justice
au riche
qui est lésé.
Qu'il protégera
le riche
qui est en danger.
Qu'il répondra
aux cris
de détresse
que le riche
élève vers lui.
Mais dans quelle proportion
cela arrive-t-il
comparé au pauvre ?
Et lorsqu'il arrive
aux riches
de ce monde
de crier à l'aide,
ne reçoit-il pas
tout de suite
le secours
de personnes
aussi riches que lui
ou intéressés
par le profit
qu'ils pourraient
retirer de cette aide
qu'ils vont apporter ?
Les riches
sont moins nombreux
que les pauvres
dans ce monde.
Ils ont beaucoup
moins souvent d'aide,
besoin d'aide
que les pauvres.
Et lorsque c'est le cas,
ils reçoivent
beaucoup plus d'aide
de la part des hommes
que les pauvres.
Leurs conditions
de vie
les rendent
beaucoup moins susceptibles
de faire appel
à Dieu
et de le glorifier
en sollicitant
ses perfections
ou ses attributs.
L'exhortation
que Paul
adresse aux riches
dans sa première lettre
à Timothée
vise précisément
ce point.
Recommande
aux riches
du présent siècle
de ne pas être
orgueilleux
et de ne pas mettre
leur espérance
dans des richesses
incertaines
mais de la mettre
en Dieu
qui nous donne
avec abondance
toutes choses
pour que nous en jouissions.
Dieu n'est pas
le Dieu des pauvres
parce qu'ils sont pauvres.
il ne rejette pas
le riche
parce qu'il est riche.
Il se rendrait alors
lui-même coupable
d'acception de personnes
de favoritisme.
Dieu est le Dieu
des pauvres
car ils sont ceux
qui par leur condition
de vie
sont les plus susceptibles
d'avoir besoin de lui
de faire appel à lui
et de le glorifier
dans leur faiblesse.
Et les versets
qui confirment
cette vérité
sont très nombreux
dans la parole.
L'association
entre le pauvre
et Dieu
est parfois si forte
qu'elle rappelle
les mots du Christ
lorsqu'il s'adressa
à l'apôtre Paul
qui persécutait
son église
en disant
Paul pourquoi
me persécutes-tu ?
Proverbe 17,5
Celui qui se moque
du pauvre
outrage celui
qui l'a fait
c'est-à-dire Dieu.
Proverbe 19,17
Celui qui a pitié
du pauvre
prête à l'éternel
qui lui rendra
selon son œuvre.
Il est dans la nature
de Dieu
de secourir
le pauvre
psaume 113,7
De la poussière
il retire le pauvre
du fumier
il relève
l'indigent.
Tout ceci
nous permet
d'affirmer
que favoriser
le riche
et mépriser
le pauvre
est donc totalement
incompatible
avec la nature
même du Dieu
que nous adorons
et servons.
Mais qu'en est-il
de nous
son peuple ?
Face à la description
qu'il fait
de lui-même
dans sa parole
d'un Dieu
qui donc pourvoit
aux pauvres
fait droit
à la veuve
à l'orphelin
et à l'étranger
il n'est pas étonnant
que Dieu ait choisi
les pauvres
les rejetés
les méprisés
les opprimés
de ce monde
pour se constituer
un peuple.
Sa gloire
n'en est que plus éclatante
car rien d'autre
que sa grâce
sa puissance
sa générosité
sa fidélité
bref
rien d'autre
que ses glorieux attributs
ses perfections
ne peuvent expliquer
la constitution
et la préservation
d'un tel peuple
que Moïse décrit ainsi
en Deuteronome
au chapitre 7
car tu es un peuple
saint pour l'éternel
ton Dieu
l'éternel ton Dieu
t'a choisi
pour que tu fusses
un peuple
qui lui appartient
entre tous les peuples
qui sont sur la surface
de la terre
ce n'est point
parce que vous surpassez
en nombre
tous les peuples
que l'éternel
s'est attaché à vous
et qu'il vous a choisi
car vous êtes
le moindre
de tous les peuples
mais parce que
l'éternel vous aime
parce qu'il a voulu
tenir le serment
qu'il avait fait
à vos pères
l'éternel vous a fait
sortir
par sa main puissante
vous a délivré
de la maison
de servitude
de la main de Pharaon
roi d'Egypte
et David
au psaume 68
ton peuple
établit sa demeure
dans le pays
que par ta bonté
ô Dieu
tu avais préparé
pour les malheureux
par pure bonté
et selon sa seule volonté
Dieu a choisi
de se constituer
un peuple
de moins que rien
de malheureux
et de leur préparer
un pays
une demeure
d'en faire
sa possession
entre tous les peuples
de la terre
aucun mérite
aucune fierté
aucune gloire
possible
à mettre
en avant
pour ce peuple
si ce n'est le fait
d'avoir été
choisi
et béni
par Dieu
et n'est-ce pas
le but de notre existence
de prendre plaisir
dans le fait
de pouvoir glorifier
notre grand Dieu
et si le diable
nous a entraînés
dans son péché
en insufflant
en nous
le sombre désir
de nous élever
à la hauteur de Dieu
d'être indépendant
de lui
n'est-il pas la foi
salutaire pour nous
et glorieux pour Dieu
qui se constituent un peuple
d'hommes
de femmes
et d'enfants
qui n'ont aucune prétention
et aucun mérite
aux yeux du monde
n'est-ce pas là un coup fatal
porté par Dieu
à Satan
et à ses enfants
de voir que c'est sans
aucune autre richesse
que celle du Christ
que nous accédons
à la gloire
de la vie éternelle
au paradis
et que nous importe
frères et sœurs
d'être considérés
comme les moindres
des moindres
parmi les hommes
tant que le Dieu
créateur de toutes choses
nous a choisis
pour être sa possession
sa possession
bien aimée
Dieu a choisi
les pauvres
pour se constituer
un peuple
parmi les autres
pour manifester
la gloire
de sa puissance
de sa fidélité
aux yeux des nations
et pour préserver
son peuple
de l'orgueil
si dangereux
pour nos âmes
comme nous l'avons vu
dimanche dernier
Dieu n'a-t-il pas
choisi les pauvres
aux yeux du monde
pour qu'ils soient riches
en la foi
demande Jacques
à ses destinataires
ne faites-vous
pas vous-même
partie de cela
leur demande-t-il
n'est-il pas
la foi salutaire
pour vous
glorieux pour Dieu
d'être compté
parmi les pauvres
aux yeux du monde
n'y a-t-il pas
une incompatibilité
totale entre
la nature de votre Dieu
la nature du peuple
que vous formez
par sa grâce
et l'acception
de personnes
que vous pratiquez
en faveur du riche
et au détriment
du pauvre
qu'en est-il
pour vous
frères et sœurs
ressentez-vous
de la joie
un sens
de privilège
immense
de l'honneur
d'être compté
parmi ceux
qui sont pauvres
aux yeux du monde
mais riches
en la foi
héritiers du royaume
que Dieu a promis
à ceux qui l'aiment
avez-vous conscience
que le Dieu
de l'univers
vous a choisi
malgré votre
pauvreté
matérielle
peut-être
mais spirituelle
certainement
pensez-vous
encore
quelque part
au fond
de vous-même
que vous méritez
ne serait-ce
qu'un peu
de faire partie
du peuple
de Dieu
non frères et sœurs
qu'à nous sommes
les moindres
des hommes
les pires
des pécheurs
mais nous sommes
le peuple
de Dieu
parce que l'éternel
a choisi
de nous aimer
parce qu'il a voulu
rester fidèle
à l'alliance
qu'il avait fait
avec nos pères
dans la foi
l'éternel
nous a fait sortir
de l'enfer
par sa main puissante
nous a délivré
de la domination
du péché
de la main
de Satan
le prince
de ce monde
Amen
Notre appel suprême
n'est-il donc pas
de refléter
le caractère
de notre Dieu
en prenant
nous aussi
soin du pauvre
en lui faisant justice
en le défendant
et en le protégeant
contre ceux
qui l'oppriment
et en l'honorant
comme Dieu l'a fait
avec nous
c'est ce que nous allons
voir maintenant
dès l'ancien testament
Dieu attend en effet
de son peuple
qu'il reflète
son caractère
et notamment
sa justice
impartiale
en ne faisant point
exception de personne
il y a presque
autant de versets
qui décrivent
le devoir
du justice
impartiale
du peuple
de Dieu
que de versets
qui décrivent
la justice
de Dieu
en faveur du pauvre
et en voici quelques-uns
Zacharie 7, 9
ainsi parlait
l'éternel des armées
à son peuple évidemment
rendez véritablement
la justice
et ayez l'un pour l'autre
de la bonté
et de la miséricorde
n'opprimez pas
la veuve et l'orphelin
l'étranger et le pauvre
et ne méditez pas
l'un contre l'autre
le mal dans vos cœurs
Proverbe 31, 9
ouvre ta bouche
juge avec justice
et défends
le malheureux
et l'indigent
Esaïe 1, verset 17
apprenez à faire le bien
recherchez la justice
protégez l'opprimé
faites droit
à l'orphelin
défendez la veuve
la nation d'Israël
devait rendre
une justice
sans corruption
une corruption
qui venait évidemment
de ceux
qui pouvaient se l'offrir
donc des riches
et donc
ne pas recevoir
de présent
ne pas se laisser
corrompre
équivalait
à ne pas favoriser
le riche
dans la justice
rendue
encore une fois
à ne pas juger
selon les apparences
mais selon la justice
à ne pas faire
acception de personnes
en faveur du riche
et au détriment du pauvre
de Ternom 16, verset 19
tu ne porteras atteinte
à aucun droit
tu n'auras point égard
à l'apparence
des personnes
et tu ne recevras
point de présent
car les présents
aveuglent
les yeux des sages
et corrompent
les paroles
des justes
mais il ne s'agissait pas
non plus
de bâtir
une nation socialiste
où par idéologie
le pauvre
serait privilégié
par rapport aux riches
et où le riche
serait haï
parce qu'il est riche
la compassion
envers les plus démunis
ne doit pas se transformer
en injustice
envers les riches
il s'agissait simplement
d'être à l'image de Dieu
impartial
de juger tout homme
quel qu'il soit
selon la vérité
et la justice
Lévitique 19, 15
tu ne commettras point
d'iniquité
dans tes jugements
tu n'auras point égard
à la personne du pauvre
et tu ne favoriseras
pas non plus
la personne du grand
mais tu jugeras
ton prochain
selon la justice
vous n'aurez point égard
à l'apparence des personnes
dans vos jugements
vous écouterez le petit
comme le grand
vous ne craindrez aucun homme
car c'est Dieu
qui rend la justice
et nous reviendrons
dimanche prochain
sur le lien
très intéressant
qu'il y a entre
le favoritisme
et la crainte
de l'homme
mais voici maintenant
comment Dieu
avertit son peuple
par la bouche
du prophète Esaïe
sur les conséquences
qui l'attendent
s'il pratique
l'injustice
malheur à ceux
qui prononcent
des ordonnances
iniques
et à ceux
qui transcrivent
des arrêts
injustes
pour refuser
justice
aux pauvres
et ravir
leurs droits
aux malheureux
de mon peuple
pour faire
des veuves
leurs proies
et des orphelins
leurs butins
que ferez-vous
au jour du châtiment
et de la ruine
qui du lointain
fondra sur vous
vers qui fuirez-vous
pour avoir du secours
!
et où laisserez-vous
votre gloire?
et malheureusement
comme nous le rappelle
souvent le pasteur Stéphane
dans ses prédications
dans le livre
d'Ézéchiel
l'injustice sociale
réelle
pas la contrefaçon
sauce woke
qu'on nous sert
aujourd'hui
fut l'une des causes
principales de jugement
de Dieu
contre son peuple
son peuple
qui l'envoya
en exil
hors du pays
qu'il lui avait donné
initialement
le malheur
s'est abattu
sur les israélites
car les riches
privèrent les pauvres
de leurs droits
et les opprimèrent
les prophètes
Amos
Jérémie
Esaïe
et Michée
sont remplis
de versets
où Dieu
expose
ce péché
de la nation d'Israël
et ses conséquences
Amos 5.11
aussi parce que
vous avez
foulé le misérable
et que vous avez
pris de lui
du blé
en présent
vous avez
bâti des maisons
en pierre de taille
mais vous ne les habiterez pas
vous avez planté
d'excellentes vignes
mais vous n'en boirez
pas le vin
car je le sais
vos crimes sont nombreux
vos péchés
se sont multipliés
vous opprimez
le juste
vous recevez
des présents
et vous violez
à la porte
le droit
des pauvres
Amos 2.6
ainsi parle l'éternel
à cause de trois crimes
d'Israël
même de quatre
je ne révoque pas
mon arrêt
parce qu'ils ont
vendu le juste
pour de l'argent
et le pauvre
pour une paire
de souliers
ils aspirent
à voir la poussière
de la terre
sur la tête
des misérables
et ils violent
le droit
des malheureux
et puisque son peuple
a échoué
à rendre
une justice
impartiale
et même
aller plus loin
en opprimant
intentionnellement
le pauvre
et en y trouvant
même du plaisir
Dieu lui-même
s'avance
au devant
de son peuple
pour plaider
en faveur
des opprimés
l'éternel
se présente
pour plaider
il est debout
pour juger
les peuples
l'éternel
entre en jugement
avec les anciens
de son peuple
et avec ses chefs
vous avez brouté
la vigne
la dépouille
du pauvre
est dans vos maisons
de quel droit
foulez-vous
mon peuple
et écrasez-vous
la face des pauvres
dit le Seigneur
l'éternel
des armées
et à cause
de son injustice
de sa convoitise
et de son
acception
de personne
le jugement
de Dieu
sur son peuple
est arrêté
Miché 3
verset 9
écoutez donc ceci
chef de la maison
de Jacob
et prince
de la maison
d'Israël
vous qui avez
en horreur
la justice
et qui pervertissez
tout ce qui est droit
vous qui bâtissez
Sion avec le sang
et Jérusalem
avec l'iniquité
ces chefs
jugent pour des présents
ces sacrificateurs
enseignent
pour un salaire
et ces prophètes
prédisent
pour de l'argent
et ils osent
s'appuyer sur l'éternel
ils disent
l'éternel n'est-il
pas au milieu de nous
le malheur
ne nous atteindra pas
c'est pourquoi
à cause de vous
Sion sera
labouré
comme un champ
Jérusalem
deviendra
un monceau
de pierre
et la montagne
du temple
une sommité
couverte
de bois
et d'ailleurs
regardez comment
Dieu
décrit la cause
de la chute
de son peuple
dans un chapitre
par ailleurs
très touchant
que je vous invite
à lire en entier
lorsque vous le pourrez
où Dieu compare
son peuple
à une femme
autrefois délaissée
qu'il a rendu
belle
magnifique
et qu'il a
fini par épouser
voici ce qu'il dit
Ézéchiel 16
mais tu t'es confié
dans ta beauté
et tu t'es
prostitué
à la faveur
de ton nom
tu as prodigué
tes prostitutions
à tous les passants
tu t'es livré
à eux
se confier
dans sa beauté
s'enorgueillir
et trahir
cela ne vous rappelle
t-il pas
la description
de la chute
de Satan
par le même
prophète Ézéchiel
quelques chapitres
plus loin
son coeur
s'est enorgueilli
de sa beauté
et il dit
j'élèverai mon trône
au-dessus
des étoiles de Dieu
c'est bien
l'esprit de Satan
qui encore
et toujours
corrompit
le coeur des Israélites
les poussant
à honorer
ceux qui frappent
les yeux
en favorisant
les riches
en opprimant
les pauvres
pour finir
par appeler
le juste jugement
de Dieu
sur eux
et nous pourrions
citer tellement
d'autres versets
mais je pense
que cela est suffisamment
clair pour vous
à ce stade
favoriser le riche
et mépriser le pauvre
est donc incompatible
non seulement
avec la nature
de Dieu
mais aussi
avec la nature
et l'appel
du peuple de Dieu
à exercer
une justice
impartiale
comprenez-vous mieux
l'importance
de cette exhortation
la gravité
de cet avertissement
de Jacques
dans ses versets
les chrétiens
de ces églises
s'apprêtent
à poser le pied
sur la même
pente glissante
qui envoya
les Israélites
en exil
car ils oublient
qui Dieu est
ils oublient
qui ils sont
et quel est
leur appel
en tant que
peuple de Dieu
ce sont des rappels
dont nous avons
constamment besoin
si nous ne voulons pas
déshonorer notre Dieu
compromettre le message
de l'évangile
par notre attitude
et nous placer
sous sa juste
et sévère discipline
nous avons beaucoup
cité l'Ancien Testament
jusqu'ici
en parlant de la nation
d'Israël
mais après tout
nous sommes
dans la lettre
de Jacques
qui s'adresse
à des chrétiens
du Nouveau Testament
alors
qu'en est-il
de l'Église
est-il
elle aussi
un peuple
formé par Dieu
constitué
de pauvres
appelés à avoir
l'un pour l'autre
de la bonté
et de la miséricorde
et à ne pas
opprimer le pauvre
la veuve
et l'orphelin
vous vous doutez bien
que la réponse
est oui
oui car Dieu
n'a pas changé
que ce soit
dans son être
ou dans ses attentes
envers son peuple
comme le montre
clairement
ces versets de Jacques
que nous étudions en ce moment
ainsi que de nombreux autres
du Nouveau Testament
notre Seigneur Jésus Christ
Dieu le Fils
l'image du Dieu invisible
fut lors de son ministère terrestre
le modèle
suprême
d'amour
de justice
et de soin
envers les pauvres
à qui il annonça
en premier
la bonne nouvelle
du royaume de Dieu
lui aussi
comme Dieu
dans l'Ancien Testament
plaida en faveur des pauvres
contre ceux
qui les opprimaient
comme dans ce passage
que nous avons cité
dimanche dernier
où Jésus expose
l'exploitation
que font
les pharisiens
des plus vulnérables
en reprenant
les mêmes mots
que le prophète
Esaïe
Luc 20 46
gardez-vous des scribes
qui aiment
à se promener
en robe longue
à être salués
dans les places publiques
qui recherchent
les premiers sièges
dans les synagogues
toi
assieds-toi ici
à cette place d'honneur
et les premières places
dans les festins
qui dévorent
les maisons des veuves
et qui font pour
l'apparence
encore et toujours
de longues prières
ils seront jugés
plus sévèrement
par compassion
réelle
Jésus guérit
miraculeusement
des aveugles
des paralytiques
des lépreux
rejetés de la société
il ressuscita même
le fils unique
d'une veuve
il n'hésita pas
à manger
et à discuter
publiquement
avec ceux
que les responsables
juifs méprisaient
et alla comme Dieu
jusqu'à s'identifier
aux pauvres
j'ai eu faim
et vous m'avez donné
à manger
et les justes
lui répondront
mais Seigneur
quand avons-nous vu
avoir faim
et avons-nous donné
à manger
et le roi
leur répondra
je vous le dis
en vérité
toutes les fois
que vous avez fait
ces choses
à l'un de ses plus petits
de mes frères
c'est à moi
que vous les avez faites
remarquez-vous
qui répond
à la question
des justes
dans ce passage
le roi
Jésus Christ
était un homme
pauvre sur terre
mais il était
le fils de Dieu
le créateur
et le possesseur
de toutes choses
il était lui-même
pauvre aux yeux
des hommes
vivant parmi les pauvres
mangeant avec eux
tout en étant le roi
tout comme nous sommes
pauvres aux yeux
du monde
mais héritiers
de son royaume
aux yeux de Dieu
Dieu le fils
est fait semblable
à nous
pour que nous soyons
rendus semblables
à lui
lui le roi des cieux
devenu pauvre
aux yeux du monde
pour faire
des misérables
que nous étions
les héritiers
de son royaume
éternel
et même aujourd'hui
du haut
de son trône de gloire
à la droite du père
il n'a pas honte
de s'identifier
au plus petit
de ses frères
quel amour
quelle humilité
quelle compassion
que celle
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
Salomon décrivit
inspiré par le Saint-Esprit
ce que ferait
ce futur roi d'Israël
dont le règne
est éternel
psaume 72
verset 4
il fera droit
au malheureux
du peuple
il sauvera
les enfants
du pauvre
et il écrasera
l'oppresseur
car il délivrera
le pauvre
qui crie
et le malheureux
qui n'a point d'aide
il aura pitié
du misérable
et de l'indigent
et il sauvera
la vie des pauvres
tous les rois
se procèneront
devant lui
toutes les nations
le serviront
car il délivrera
le pauvre
qui crie
et le malheureux
qui n'a point d'aide
il aura pitié
du misérable
et de l'indigent
et il sauvera
la vie des pauvres
il les affranchira
de l'oppression
et de la violence
et leur sang
aura du prix
à ses yeux
Amen
Mes amis
ce roi ainsi décrit
n'est-il pas
notre sauveur
et frère Jésus Christ
ces pauvres
et ces indigents
qu'il est venu sauver
est-ce que
ce n'est pas nous
un roi
adoré des rois
parce qu'il sauve
la vie des pauvres
dont le sang
est précieux
à ses yeux
un roi serviteur
qui donne son sang
pour affranchir
les misérables pécheurs
que nous sommes
tel est notre Dieu
tel est notre roi
des rois
Jésus Christ
Gloire soit à Jésus Christ
notre bon roi
qui a eu pitié de nous
et qui nous éma
au point de donner sa vie
pour notre salut éternel
et voici maintenant
comment l'apôtre Paul
décrit l'église
dans sa première lettre
aux Corinthiens
considérez frères
que parmi vous
qui avez été appelés
il n'y a pas beaucoup
de sages selon la chair
ni beaucoup de puissants
ni beaucoup de nobles
mais Dieu a choisi
les choses folles du monde
pour confondre les sages
Dieu a choisi
les choses faibles du monde
pour confondre les fortes
et Dieu a choisi
les choses viles du monde
et celles qu'on méprise
celles qui ne sont point
pour réduire à néant
celles qui sont
afin que nulle chair
ne se glorifie devant Dieu
cela ne vous rappelle-t-il pas
la description de la nation d'Israël
des pauvres et des malheureux
gracieusement choisis par Dieu
pour être son peuple
et manifester sa gloire
aux yeux des nations
voici ce que nous sommes
selon l'apôtre Paul
frères et sœurs
des créatures faibles
viles
méprisables
qui n'existent même pas
aux yeux du monde
mais que Dieu a choisi
et rassemblé
en Jésus Christ
pour en faire son peuple
afin que nulle chair
ne se glorifie
mais soit au contraire
humilié devant Dieu
et que lui seul
soit glorifié
et finalement
que dire
de l'appel
que Dieu a pour son peuple
l'église
lui aussi
tout à fait similaire
à celui de l'Ancien Testament
et par la grâce de Dieu
qui transforme le chrétien
par la profusion du Saint-Esprit
dans son cœur
l'église du Nouveau Testament
est contrairement à Israël
davantage caractérisée
par le soin du pauvre
que par son oppression
dans l'église primitive
personne n'était dans le besoin
acte 4.34
car il n'y avait parmi eux
aucun indigent
tous ceux qui possédaient
des champs
ou des maisons
les vendaient
apportaient le prix
de ce qu'ils avaient vendu
et le déposaient
au pied des apôtres
et l'on faisait
la distribution
à chacun
selon
qu'il en avait besoin
l'ordination
des premiers diacres
avait précisément
pour but
d'assurer
une juste répartition
de l'aide matérielle
parmi les veuves
de l'assemblée
en ces temps-là
le nombre
des disciples augmentant
les hélénistes
murmurèrent
contre les hébreux
parce que leurs veuves
étaient négligées
dans la distribution
qui se faisait
chaque jour
ils élurent donc
Étienne
homme plein de foi
et d'esprit saint
Philippe, Procore, etc.
les premiers diacres
et sans surprise
Jacques
celui qui a écrit
cette lettre
exhorte l'apôtre Paul
à prendre soin
des pauvres
ce que Paul fera
Galate 2.10
et ayant reconnu
la grâce
qui m'avait été accordée
Jacques
ses faces
et Jean
qui sont regardés
comme des colonnes
me donnèrent à moi
et à Barnabas
la main d'association
afin que nous allassions
nous vers les païens
et eux vers les circoncis
ils nous recommandèrent
seulement
de nous souvenir
des pauvres
ce que j'ai bien
eu soin
de faire
la suite
de l'histoire
de l'église
est aussi caractérisée
par le soin
des pauvres
dès le deuxième siècle
de l'histoire
de l'église
des collègues de charité
sont organisés
pour les besoins
des pauvres
entre le quatrième
et le sixième siècle
les premières structures
hospitalières
sont créées
pour accueillir
malades, pauvres
voyageurs
ou étrangers
Jean Chrysostome
et Saint Augustin
prêchèrent sur
l'obligation
d'aider le pauvre
et voyaient
dans ce soin du pauvre
une expression
concrète
de l'amour
du prochain
et de l'imitation
du Christ
au Moyen-Âge
les monastères
sont fondés
et ils distribuent
de la nourriture
des soins médicaux
et accueillent
les orphelins
la charité
s'est institutionnalisée
par la pratique
de l'aumône
et des hospices
et enfin
les réformateurs
comme Calvin
ont renforcé
la structure
diaconale
pour secourir
pauvres
réfugiés
et malades
sur les fonds
de l'église
Martin Busser
à Strasbourg
John Knox
en Écosse
établissent
des règles strictes
pour que personne
dans l'église
ne manque
du nécessaire
et cette oeuvre
humanitaire
et sociale
de l'église
envers les plus pauvres
continue
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans le monde entier
il est clair
à la lumière
de la Bible
et de l'histoire
de l'église
qu'une des manifestations
majeures
du fruit de l'esprit
dans la vie du chrétien
est précisément
le soin
des plus démunis
car l'esprit de Dieu
nous retransforme
à l'image de Christ
lui-même
l'image du Dieu invisible
qui est le Dieu
qui fait droit
aux pauvres
et qui donne sa vie
pour sauver
le pauvre
si quelqu'un
possède les biens
du monde
et que voyant son frère
dans le besoin
il lui ferme
ses entrailles
comment l'amour
de Dieu
demeure-t-il
en lui ?
nous en arrivons
par ce verset
au niveau
individuel
il ne s'agit pas
seulement de la nature
de Dieu
de la nature
et de l'appel
de son peuple
de manière générale
il s'agit aussi
de la nouvelle nature
et de l'appel
de chacun
de ses enfants
nous ne pouvons pas
nous cacher
au milieu de la masse
de chrétiens
en nous disant
que nous prenons soin
avec eux du pauvre
comment pouvons-nous
nous prétendre chrétiens
s'il face à toutes
ces évidences bibliques
que nous venons de lire
nous n'aidons pas
notre frère
qui est dans le besoin
comment pourrions-nous
être comptés
parmi ceux
qui aiment Dieu
si nous n'aimons pas
les pauvres
lorsque Jésus
s'identifie à eux
au point de dire
lorsque vous prenez soin
du moindre de ces petits
c'est de moi
que vous prenez soin
notre attitude
envers les plus pauvres
et notamment au sein
de l'église locale
démontre
l'authenticité
de l'amour
que nous avons
pour le Christ
si bien que
si nous négligeons
le pauvre
c'est Christ
que nous outrageons
l'enfant de Dieu
en qui l'amour
du Père habite
prendra soin
comme son Père
du pauvre
frères et sœurs
aviez-vous conscience
que favoriser le riche
et mépriser le pauvre
était à ce point
opposé
à l'être de Dieu
à la nature
de son peuple
et à l'appel
et n'est-ce pas
réconfortant pour nous
de constater
à quel point notre Dieu
est bon
juste
et compatissant
n'est-ce pas
apaisant pour notre âme
lorsque nous constatons
tant d'abus
et d'injustices
de toutes sortes
à travers le monde
et dans l'église
de savoir que Dieu
voit et retient
toutes ces choses
et qu'aucun de ses péchés
ne restera impuni
notre Dieu
est le Dieu
des pauvres
des exclus
de tous ceux
qui comme eux
crient vers lui
pour recevoir son aide
il se plaît
à les écouter
à leur répondre
il compatit
à leur détresse
à leur souffrance
il se glorifie
en les secourant
et en les élevant
en Jésus Christ
au-dessus
de toutes les nations
verset 5
pour qu'il soit
riche
en la foi
et héritier
du royaume
qu'il a promis
à ceux
qui l'aiment
oui
chère assemblée
car le but de Dieu
n'est pas de se constituer
un peuple de pauvres
pour les garder
dans la pauvreté
s'il manifeste
toute l'étendue
de sa justice
de sa compassion
et de sa puissance
en se constituant
un peuple
avec les plus démunis
de ce monde
Dieu veut aussi
manifester l'étendue
de sa générosité
de sa bonté
de sa richesse
de sa joie
en les bénissant
abondamment
et en faisant d'eux
les hommes et les femmes
les plus riches
de l'univers
mais il s'agit
cette fois-ci
d'une vraie richesse
d'un vrai royaume
et non d'une contrefaçon
que Satan
nous offre
pour perdre
notre âme
Satan veut faire
de nous
des enfants gâtés
qui ont tout
tout de suite
et sans effort
sans persévérance
c'est ce qu'il a promis
à Ève
mange ce fruit
et tu atteindras
d'un coup
et sans effort
la récompense finale
que Dieu vous réserve
et parce que nous avons cru
à ce mensonge
Jésus-Christ
dans son humanité
a dû obéir à la loi
!
pour mériter
notre entrée
au paradis
à cause de notre péché
il a dû souffrir
et mourir sur la croix
pour expier nos fautes
devant Dieu
bien qu'il était déjà
le roi des rois
il a dû vivre
la pauvreté
l'humiliation
et la mort
avant de ressusciter
et d'être intronisé
à la droite de Dieu
en tant que Dieu homme
mais aujourd'hui
c'est bien
de son trône
de puissance infinie
de justice parfaite
et d'autorité suprême
qu'il règne sur son Église
et au-dessus
de toute domination
qu'il a reçu du Père
en récompense
de ses œuvres parfaites
lors de son ministère terrestre
sa gloire était voilée
cachée aux yeux des hommes
mais elle était bien réelle
et à ceux
dont le Saint-Esprit
ouvre les yeux
elle devient alors
aussi bien visible
frères et sœurs
nous pouvons être pauvres
aux yeux du monde
ne rien posséder matériellement
ne rien accomplir de grand
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
vivre des vies
qui aux yeux des hommes
sont invisibles
transparentes
personne ne se souviendra
de nous
nous n'en sommes pas moins
chacun d'entre nous
héritiers du royaume
que Jésus-Christ
nous a promis
à nous
qui l'aimons
aimez-vous Jésus-Christ
aimez-vous
Jésus-Christ
on n'a jamais fait aussi
compliqué et simple
à la fois
pour hériter
d'un tel patrimoine
il vous suffit
d'aimer Jésus-Christ
pour l'obtenir
entièrement
et définitivement
heureux ceux
à qui le Saint-Esprit
permet de confesser
qu'ils sont pauvres en esprit
car le royaume des cieux
est à eux
si Dieu ne nous avait pas choisis
nous
misérables rebelles
nous serions encore
en train de danser
au milieu du bal macabre
du traître Satan
nous croyons
beaux
riches
et en sécurité
alors que nous étions
spirituellement hideux
pauvres
et morts
mais pour nous
à qui Dieu
a gracieusement accordé
le don de la repentance
et de la foi
en Jésus-Christ
alors même si nous sommes
pauvres aux yeux du monde
nous sommes déjà riches
en Jésus-Christ
car le Saint-Esprit
nous a unis à lui
et tout ce qui est vrai
de Jésus-Christ
le Dieu homme
est vrai de nous
nous sommes morts
avec lui
ressuscités avec lui
et nous régnons
avec lui
dès aujourd'hui
et la parole nous dit
que nous jugerons
les anges déchus
et les nations
avec lui
tout comme la divinité
du fils
était pour un temps
voilée
mais bien présente
notre nouvelle nature
et notre nouvelle citoyenneté
sont encore voilées
mais elles sont bien réelles
et déjà présentes
nous n'étions rien
aux yeux du monde
nous n'étions pas un peuple
tous dispersés
parmi les nations du monde
dans notre idolâtrie
regardez-vous
combien de nations
d'ethnies
de langues
et de niveaux de prospérité
sont réunis dans cette salle
qu'est-ce qui peut bien expliquer
un tel rassemblement
si ce n'est l'Esprit de Dieu
qui nous attire
tous vers notre glorieux
sauveur Jésus-Christ
pour l'adorer ensemble
Dieu est d'ores et déjà
glorifié par un tel miracle
l'Église
mais il le sera davantage encore
lorsque la gloire
de ses enfants
éclatera aux yeux
de toute la création
ce jour-là
tous les masques
tous les costumes
tous les maquillages
tous les voiles spirituelles
tomberont
tout sera mis à nu
devant le Dieu
trois fois saint
et alors
tandis que ceux
qui se croyaient riches
et glorieux
aux yeux des hommes
constateront
toute l'étendue
de leur horrible misère
un à un
les enfants de Dieu
se mettront à resplendir
d'une gloire
sans pareil
celle du Christ ressuscité
et seront invités
par le Père
à entrer dans son royaume éternel
tel est notre héritage
mes frères et sœurs
et sœurs